testez la question prêt à se rendre
à Dieu qu'est-il arrivé à Mueller
le mauler buveur de première classe joueurs
quelques visiteurs parmi nous ici aujourd'hui nous
étions au service avec votre
pasteur je n'ai pas vu ces hommes depuis des
décennies ils représentent une période canine
parce que  de mon fils je suis venu ici j'ai trouvé que
vous alliez être enterrés à Arlington et je
me demandais si vous pouviez venir
avec moi je ramène Larry à la maison je pensais que
nous allions à un enterrement nous allons
à un enterrement
ce que vous allez faire sangle  le cercueil sur
le toit de votre voiture nous pourrions faire ça
vous allez ramener le canard et essayer de le
rendre amusant vous les gars prêt pour une
aventure allons y
qu'est ce que vous sentez l'urine j'adore c'est
comme le parfum officiel des choses de la ville
qui entrent dans votre tête et sortent
de votre bouche
vous vous inquiétez trop c'est pourquoi vos cheveux
sont si beaux pourriez-vous résister à un homme dans
cet uniforme je ne pense pas que je pourrais vous être
là pour vos frères c'est tout ce que je
remarque vraiment
qui a terriblement baissé  rapide  k buvant
Fortuna tu as un vieux et ennuyeux